[Applause]
an election victory
widely seen as flawed followed by a
crackdown
against anyone challenging the incumbent
president's rule
alexander lukashenko drew the wrath of
democratic states last august
they imposed sanctions on his regime for
human rights abuses
yet it appears to have done nothing to
change his behavior
propped up by close ally president putin
of russia now the de facto hijacking of
a european flight to arrest a journalist
has left politicians around the world
warning tougher action must be taken
it's unprecedented and very abharant
action like the state terrorism action
against the european community countries
are reacting
with belarus on the agenda of an eu
summit
while nato ambassadors are also due to
meet
diplomacy not military force the focus
the uk moved first banning british
carriers from flying through belarussian
airspace
stopping belarus's state-owned airline
from using uk airports
and summoning the belarusian ambassador
to downing street
sanctions are also being considered by
the uk and other allies
including halting energy pipelines in
belarus
other options could be to curb the
regime's access to western sources of
finance
and its ability to trade though there
must be a balance between hurting
president lukashenko
and harming his people there are good
reasons why belarusians
might want to leave their country
including when they're fleeing
persecution
so if we're talking about transport
links any
restrictions that the eu imposes
would need to ensure that we're not
unwittingly
hurting those who may wish to
flee to safety in neighboring countries
a need for consensus in the eu could
prompt states like cyprus
with good ties to moscow to limit any
punishment of belarus
analysts hope not or else the bad
behavior could continue
debrahing sky news